yeah all right all right
welcome back uh so our next speaker is
jen feng liu from duke uh he's actually
uh one of more
of our most serious uh remote
participants for the semester
and you always see his name in those
zoom meetings so he's going to talk to
you about high procursive sampling
dynamics take it away gentlemen
thanks a lot for the organizers for
putting together such a nice workshop
and for the kind invitation
unfortunately it couldn't be there in
person i plan to come in october though
so that
to meet you guys in person and to
discuss
uh so what i'm going to talk about today
is about some of our recent works on
understanding the convergence
i mean analysis for hypochose of
sampling dynamics
i don't think this word has appeared in
the workshop but i mean it's actually
something
familiar to many of you
um i should mention that this is a
series of work and joined with my former
student utah and lee wong and lehigh is
actually in the workshop so that if you
have any questions you can ask him
during the break
okay so um
i guess everyone here is uh i mean we're
all here to talk about sampling so that
i can just basically skip these slides
but just to give you some ideas of where
we come from so that we want to
understand the convergence rate and
asymptotic variance and so that to
determine the efficiency of mcmc
sampling algorithms
okay
and now
our purpose here i mean so for today is
to consider sampling problems in high
dimensional space with continuous state
variables so it's uh so it's x and in r
d so it's a it's a full
space sampling problem and we'll be
mostly uh focused on uh strongly log
concave distributions so while some of
the results actually apply in more
general
cases
and so for this case as we have seen uh
during the workshop and also during
tutorial that a common design principle
of sampler mcmc samplers is to first
start with a continuous time markov
process and then do a time disclosation
perhaps the most famous example for that
is the overtime long-term dynamics or i
mean in statistics machine learning
literature known as long-term dynamics
uh so the the dynamics just this is like
a random noise perturbed gradient flow
under the potential u
and one can uh show that i mean so this
is the environment of the dynamics and i
mean one can use this i mean as a
sampling dynamics for the gibbs measure
and as always we are hoping for like
fast convergence of the sampling
dynamics to equilibrium
and for this case
it's actually sort of easy to see and
for that i mean so the focus of my
target the techniques that we'll be
discussing this talk is actually pd
technique so i also choose this topic to
connect to i mean two themes of this
program
so um one way to analyze this is to
write down the background backward
chromograph equation associated with the
sde
so this describes the evolution of
observable if you start with some
observable h0 and if you flow the time
to infinity and the solution will
converge to a constant and it converges
to expectation of the observable h0 so
which is what we want to sample
and now so the long term behavior of the
sampling dynamics or the overdub german
dynamics is well understood and there
are many
approaches to do that but one easy
approach is through the concurrent
inquiry
so if the potential if the distribution
satisfies a pancaja equality in this
type so that you bound the variance of
the distribution in terms of the
gradient of h squared with a pancake
constant m
and so then we can we know that it will
exponentially converge okay and just as
example that so if your potential is m
strongly convex means that hessian of
the potential is bounded from below by m
then it satisfies i mean the
distribution satisfied functional
inequality with this constant m here
okay and so i guess uh it's sort of
familiar to everyone that under the
assumption of conquering on i mean the
sampling dynamics converges
exponentially with the weight given by
the pancreatic constant in l2
okay and i mean this is a simple proof
it's actually one line proof for this
it's the standard energy method you
multiply the pde on the left hand side
by h and then take the time derivative
okay
so i hope this is clear so bar okay so
this is an introduction of what we know
for the uh overdub the case or its
reversible case
okay so the focus of our uh kind of
consideration of work is really try to
understand i mean the uh quantitative
convergence rate for the uh hypocrisy of
cases or in other words uh in other
words for that is a non-reversible
sampling dynamics and the perhaps the
most famous example at least to this
audience is the so-called underdamped
launcher dynamics or the kinetic
launcher and dynamics
which i mean you can this is sort of
related with the hmc as we also see
later
but i mean so this part is the
hamiltonian dynamics so the positioning
uh the time derivative of position is
given by the velocity and the time
durative velocity is given by the force
which consists of three parts so one is
the gradient part which is similar to
the overdamped case before and so that
this consists of the hamiltonian part of
dynamics
and then we have the noise and
dissipations
okay where this the only parameter here
and i kind of non-dimensionalized so
that only parameter is the gamma which
is the friction parameter
physically speaking
okay
and
i mean the reason that this is called
underdamped laundromat dynamics and i
mean or the actually in physics is
usually just known as algebra dynamics
is because that if you send
the friction parameter to infinity and
the rescale time properly then it will
actually converge to the overdone
dynamics
and one can also show that using either
pde or just check i mean the generator
for example that invariant measure for
this longitudinal dynamics is given by
product measure
where in the variable x is just the
gibbs measure that we want to sample and
in the v is a gaussian
pressure
so now we try to understand the uh the
convergence rate for this long-term
dynamics i mean the purpose of that is i
mean hopefully once we understand the
convergence of the continuous dynamics
then we can think about time discussions
and getting the estimate for the
discrete uh sampling mcmc samplers
and as before i mean kind of parallel to
the over down the case
uh one natural approach is to think
about the pde analog i mean of
the analog of the backhoe curve
coefficient that we have seen before or
four compound equation
and in this case for the kinetic long
division dynamics the corresponding
chromograph equation is given by this
i mean where the generator consists of
two parts so one is the hamiltonian part
which is actually not revisible because
this is kind of a rotation if you think
about what this action is on the phase
space
and the other part is the fluctuation
dissipation part which consists of the
noise and also dissipation of the
velocity and this part is actually
reversible
and i mean this i mean if you think
about if you neglect
say for a moment that neglect this part
and just think about dynamics in v this
is actually can be viewed as overtime
dynamics for the gaussian potential
so and of course i mean once you write
down generator you can check explicitly
that the measure is given by what i
claim to be so it which is the row
infinity
so now the question is that i mean so if
we think about the convergence rate of
overdamped as we said before that if you
think about convergence rate in
chi-square or in l2
the rate is given by m which is the
concurrent constant of the measure
so what's the case of the underdamped
case okay so this is actually the
question that we started asking
ourselves a couple years ago
and so if there was any i mean so by it
you think in some sense you are kind of
augmenting the state space by
introducing these auxiliary variables
which is the velocity from physical
point of view and the question is
whether that helps
and
indeed it helps and this is the theorem
that we proved a couple years ago
so under some technical assumptions what
one can show is that the
in l2
the sampling dynamics actually converges
exponentially
with a rate by lambda which is given
explicitly by this formula
where i mean so the gamma is the
friction parameter uh that we have we
have in the dynamics and m is the
primary constant of the of the gibbs
measure that you want to sample i mean
related with this u for example
if i mean if we know what m is and we
can choose gamma to optimize this rate
and if you choose gamma
if you choose gamma proportional to the
square root of m
then the rate that you will get is the
square root of m
and let me just mention that we have uh
results of the convenience rate and
assets for more general cases but i'm
going to focus on this particular case
here which is that i mean you can think
of it as strongly a concave case
okay and where this m is really just a
concave
parameter
okay so let me make a couple remarks so
first of all i mean so this is i mean if
we simplify the situation by setting the
average of the observable is equal to
zero and this is just the summary of the
results so that it exponentially
converges in l2
in the dual space of the observable
right i mean with the rate which is the
square root of m
okay
and by the way i mean so this we are
thinking taking the perspective of
observable here but if you're thinking
in terms of the probability measure of
the forward equation this means that the
chi-square divergence converges with
this weight
okay
and first of all if you compare with the
over-dump decay dynamics remember that
over thermodynamics has the exponential
rate but with uh
with the worst constant
okay i mean thinking about case we are
always thinking about case where m is
small so that this is
slower than this
okay so indeed you see that the
underdamped launch event actually
accelerates the convergence
and also it's not hard to check that
this root m dependence of the
convergence rate is optimal
because you can take u to be just a
simple gaussian and you i mean by
explicit calculation of what's happening
of a gaussian measure on the dynamics
you can check that this is the optimal
range you cannot get anything better
than this
and also i mean there are many
techniques available to get quantitative
estimate for the convergence rate for
longevity and as far as as we know that
this is only a technique giving root m
up to date
okay and also i mean because we have
showed the convergence in chi-square so
this also implies the convergence in
relative entropy and total variation
which are all included
okay any questions for this before i
move on
just making sure that i'm not i'm still
connected
so one thing that i want to uh mention
and actually i think bring to attention
of this community is that i mean so
oftentimes we spend a lot of time to
analyze uh
mala or
hmc type of arizona but actually there
are many interesting sampling algorithms
out there and recently proposed by
statisticians and applied mathematicians
and i feel they're actually worse
considerations by the community trying
to especially in the cs community trying
to establish non-symptomatic bonds
so for that purpose actually i've spent
some time trying to introduce you some
new dynamics maybe so which as far as i
see have haven't been covered in this uh
program
so i mean there was a new family of
sampling dynamics called piecewise
domestic market process or pdmp for
short
and so the their kind of uh behavior is
a bit like uh so you have a random clock
which is uh
you can think of it as poisson clock
and i mean besides between the clock
wings okay
and so that dynamic just follows some
deterministic trajectory so that's why
it's called the deterministic micro
process so peace but it's piecewise so
that when the random clock
happens and then it does something and
to to ensure that you're actually
sampling the correct measure
one of the example that is perhaps uh
familiar uh because it's very related
with hmc so it's the randomized hmc
algorithm okay so uh so it's almost the
same as the standard hmc but instead of
the standard hmc where you run the
hematoma dynamics for fixed duration of
time capital t
and then you redraw the velocity
so here what you do is that you run the
dynamic hypertonic dynamics
but you at the same time you have a
clock which rings at a rate that is
gamma
and when the person clock wins
what you do is that you just redraw the
velocity according to adoption
distribution
so it is the hamiltonian hmc algorithm
but for the time duration t which
follows a
exponential
random variable with rate which given by
gamma
okay
i hope this is clear
and now this is one of the examples of
the pdmp dynamics but then there are
more i mean many more recent
examples so one of the uh i mean kind of
i will introduce two of the uh kind of
more popular ones that is kind of used
these days so one is so-called zig-zag
sampler
so uh this dynamics is actually quite
interesting to some extent and what it
does is that i mean so forget about this
part first
so only if forget about this part first
then only look at this
okay
so if the dynamics if this is my only
part of my generator
then what the dynamics i mean goes it's
just a straight line so what this says i
mean in terms of the ode it's just that
the x dot
is equal to v
so with a give with a fixed velocity the
particle just flies in a straight line
so as you can see from uh from the
picture here maybe uh not large enough
i'm not sure how it's views in in person
but you can see that this follows this
directory
and then it i mean these there were
several there were several person clocks
my wing and when it wins it does sell a
couple of things so if this person clock
wins this part of the generator what it
does is just that it redraw the velocity
as a gaussian random variable
and if only with this then there is no
reason that this will sample the correct
measure that that we want which is the
gibbs one which is a gibbs measure and
then you add on top of this person clock
a i mean a bunch of another person
clocks which is i mean the number is
given by the dimensioning of the problem
and for this one clock what you do is
that whenever they ring
you flip the velocity in that direction
so imagine that you are flying in this
direction
i mean previously i mean as we as we
said we always go straight line
okay and whenever some i mean one of the
person clock rings and what you do is
just that you flip the velocity in that
direction so which is this direction
that we're talking about
okay you flip the velocity so that's the
reflection and you go to that i mean you
follow the trajectory in that new
direction so as you can see also in the
picture here that you go here and then
one clock wins i mean you flip the
velocity direction in x1 and you go back
there and then you're going like this
okay
and then you pick the rate of this
flipping of the directions according to
the partial derivative related with
partial derivative of potential
multiplied by the velocity and then you
can check that actually for this
generator i mean you can check that this
l star acting on the the rho infinity
before is actually equal to zero which
means that the environment of this
sampling dynamics is agrees with what we
want to sample
okay so this is known as zigzag sampler
introduced in 2019
and there is a very similar kind of
related sampler which is called bouncy
particle which is slightly introduced
slightly earlier in the physics
literature and also picked up by in the
machine learning literature later on
which is very similar so that you follow
some straight lines and then when the
clock wins you either you draw the
velocity from reduction
or in this case you flip but not
according to a coordinate plane you flip
according to the gradient of u so the
level set of the potential functions
okay and so this is like a cartoon that
shows the trajectory of this under the
bouncy particle process
okay
and one advantage that why people like
these things is that i mean so often
times we know that if we have a lot of
data that we need to
estimate the gradient using some
stochastic gradient estimations
and now if you're using long-divided
sampler or using hmc and you're not
using the accurate gradient
then that will induce bias
but one nice properties of these zig zag
opposite particle samplers is that even
with the stochastic gradient they could
be made unbiased
okay so i'm not going into details of
these things and those applications but
i mean i've been uh collaborating with
some statisticians at duke on these
things and if you're interested we can
talk more afterwards
can i ask a quick question yes
so can you come back to the previous
slide for a sec sure
uh okay i see so i was looking for where
uh graduates so you only need the
coordinates of the of of you okay yeah
exactly so this is actually part we'll
come back to so it's a bit like a
carnate algorithm that ching discussed
earlier in the workshop and it's
actually for each balance you only need
partial derivative okay the other
question that i have is could you remind
us what the role of gamma is in the in
the discrete time uh hmc because you
only discussed the continuous time hmc
and so yeah one over gamma is kind of
like t
so which is the duration of the hm at
the hamiltonian battery on average
okay thanks so the smog in other words
the small gamma is that you are running
the hamiltonian dynamics for longer
before we draw the same rejoice velocity
any expectation the gamma plays the same
role right for this exactly all right
thanks
i mean the purpose of the randomized hmc
by the way is to actually uh kill the
resonance that could happen if you run
the uh the gamma at fixed interval so
that i mean so you may run into troubles
over that so that's i mean that's i mean
and also for an analysis on a continuous
level it's slightly easier
let me to formulate the problem this way
okay so now i mean so we have results i
mean which is actually follows from a
similar analysis framework as the
long-term dynamics for the quantitative
convergence rate for these dynamics as
well
um so i mean we're summarizing the
results of these pdmps on this single
page and the typical message i guess is
that for the randomized hmc as you can
imagine because it's so connected with
long-term dynamics and actually on the
continuous level the convergence rate is
the same oh by the way i should mention
that when i write o i mean so everything
i implied is uh is i mean is absolute
constant so that there was nothing
dimension dependent of anything like
that hidden in all variables okay so
that all these things are dimensionally
independent except the last one
and now for zig zag
it's deteriorated a little bit by
condition number where the l is i mean
so for simplicity here we assume that
the the gradient u is smooth so that the
hashing is bounded from above by l and
from below by small m so that this is
the condition number that you can view
and which is sort of reasonable because
i mean as you can see that in the zigzag
because the algorithm design is designed
knowing explicitly coordinate planes so
that if you kind of
make it the potential much skewed and
because the algorithm does not know that
and has i mean it's not adaptive to that
so that it will suffer from the
condition number okay i mean you can
make it more adaptive but then we're
talking about the originals exactly
and for bps i mean we do not know
whether it's sharp or not but i mean the
best we can prove
is that it will be deteriorated by root
of d
in the in the convergence rate
and i mean as far as we know that all
these governance rates are state of arts
as of today
okay
so
of course i mean many of the audience
here are interesting algorithms rather
than pd analysis so that i mean as just
uh
sorry to interpret it yes just one more
question so those previous results again
this is for like exact uh simulation of
them hamiltonian dynamics for example
for rmhmc you're assuming that you have
exact diameter dynamics in between two
uh clocks yeah exactly so that i mean
we're talking about pde results here and
i'm i'm
i'm coming to the algorithm okay all
right thank you all right thank you so
all these are continuous time results
are for pdes
call for the sd itself
okay
so now let's come to the algorithms
and the zig zag sampler i mean and one
advantage and it's also very similar for
bouncy particle samplers but i'm going
to focus on this exact sampler and i
mean the reason one reason is because we
can obtain a slightly better rate here
okay
and one advantage for that is that you
actually do not make any disposition
error
because the only dynamics that you need
to integrate is as simple as this right
so it's just a straight line
and so unlike hamiltonian dynamics or
longevity that we need to discretize it
to make errors i mean so in principle
you can simulate this exactly
okay of course there is no free launch
and whereas the price the price is
actually you need to pay the price to
simulate the presumed process and
remember that for zig zag process what
do we have a generator is something like
i mean we sum over each directions
and then there will be something that is
v i and partial derivative of u in that
direction so this is a rate
okay
and to sample
to sample a person
clock with this rate so if you do it
naively then this will be a nightmare
because what you need to do is that you
need to integrate this along the
trajectory and then and kind of do a
transformation of the exponential random
variable
which is i mean not i mean which is
unpractical and then you're also making
errors
and
one way to do that oh actually there is
a generator here one way to do that
is that you introduce the upper bound
for these things so that
if you can simulate a poisson process
which with a rate that is higher that is
guaranteed to be higher than any i mean
of the rate that you occur in the
inhomogeneous person process
then you can simulate the poisson
process with a larger rate
and then do a acceptance rejection
afterwards
okay to get the correct exact i mean
this is kind of like a rejection
sampling uh but for the person process
and to get exact simulation for uh for
the inhomogeneous person process and
this is known in the literature called
personal theming
and for that what you need to do is to
get a uniform upper bound
for this rate
okay
now i mean this in general this is a
hard question right because i mean this
depends on your knowledge of the what
potential look like
but if you assume that we're in the
setting of strongly concave
distributions with uh which i mean with
known parameters of the uh literature's
constant and the strongly uh convexing
complexity parameters then that is
possible i mean because i mean this is
just a gradient right so you can bond it
by using the lipschitz constant of the
gradient
okay
and so in that context
okay if you have a strong concave and
then you can come up with a upper bound
using the uh using the potential i'm
using the uh l of the electricity's
constant potential
and then we'll give you a practical
algorithm
okay and the algorithm that we analyzed
the complexity i mean together with
lihan uh last year i mean for this exact
sampler and what we can prove is the
following so if you assume that
potential is strongly convex and with
condition number kappa
okay
and we have to assume a warm start
assumption that chi-square i mean the
reason that we have chi-square is
because on the pde level all our
convergence results are for chi square
okay so it's l2 convergence so that's i
mean so for the warmness we also need to
assume chi-square
and for the chi square of initial
distribution with battery target it's
bounded by something like exponential d
if it's expanded d then it's not
warmness but unfortunately we need to
have log d here
okay so which is which will make it
not a feasible start
okay and under this assumption and also
if you do not acquire like a very
extremely high precision and the reason
for both of this and that is because we
cannot run this process for extremely
long time i mean before some disaster
may happen because i mean everything is
random so we need to control the wrong
time
okay i mean the total i mean total time
of the sampling dynamics which comes
into play here
okay then with these two assumptions
then with i mean but this is really mild
because this is exponentially small in d
okay but this is a
this is a restriction to our starting
point
then with high probability the zigzag
sampler would output a random variable
that was area smaller than epsilon
and the query that we need in terms of
partial derivatives is d to the three
half times kappa squared and everything
else is polylog
okay and i mean here all i mean all
these uh constants that we didn't
mention are absolute constants
okay so i mean by the way i mean i
should mention that this is the number
of partial derivatives which is related
with the question asked before so that
when each bouncing event occur we need
to do a exception rejection and that
only used the partial derivative in the
sixth assembler so if you think that the
evaluation of the partial derivative is
one over d
cheaper than the evaluation of the
gradient then effectively the cost of
the sampler is root d
times kappa square
so of course i mean this
you may want to compare this with some
of the recent works that we hear in the
workshop and also we also will talk
about their work after me i think um so
where they get uh for bala i mean we can
we should compare with mala because
we're in a hierarchy regime so our epsom
dependence is polylog and in mala they
were able to get the root half and times
kappa complexity
but i should comment that their woman is
a warm start assumption is much stronger
than ours
because their almost their one start
assumption is constant
while we are like exponentially divided
by log
johnson i wanted to ask a
clarification about that last point um
because you still have the log of the
chi-square divergence at the start in
your bound um in what sense is this warm
star assumption like
weaker
oh
um
[Music]
you get a good point yes sorry for that
take it back so i mean so yeah i think
we should say that i mean we can work
with this assumption and then you are
right that dependence here actually
depends on d
sorry for that
okay thank you
and i i mean for that actually i don't
exactly remember your bond so maybe we
can compare that afterwards
okay so uh now i mean given the
remaining time i think uh i have like 15
minutes left or 10 minutes left
uh yeah eleven
okay ten minutes so uh now i will
actually talk a little bit about the uh
the uh how we actually carry out the uh
the analysis
for the convergence rate and the
actually the framework of the analysis
are quite similar so that i'm going to
focus on the laundromat case
so uh remember that for the long-term
case what we need to do is to actually
understand the convergence of the pde uh
with the initial condition given by that
and we know that this pd will eventually
goes to those constant
okay
and now the difficulty of this analysis
from the pe point of view is that the
operator l we have is not elliptic
and because we have something first
order here and this is a rotation it's
not a diffusion
okay and this part is elliptic
and so in more technical terms this is
known as the hyperelliptic equation uh
hyperelectric operator and that's also i
mean why we call it hyperplasia
and the reason is basically because you
only have like i mean first order
derivative x but not second order
derivative of x we only have second
order to be in v direction
and as a result if you hope for
coercivity uh which in a sense is just
as simple as following so that if you
take inner product with l2
of your generator with f
and if you do integration with parts
in the in
in the previous case right so that in
the in the overdumpling case what you
will do is that if you take an
integration of parts i mean for the
generator of the overdumplicate over
them dynamics
and you can actually see that this is
just
by this is actually just the gradient
square and the l2 norm of the gradient
of g
okay and then by conquering inequality
you can use this to bind out too so this
is actually comes into the proof of the
energy method
so you want to mimic the same thing here
for this uh for the new kinetic
boundary equation and what you can you
can follow the same line of the proof
and then you can do incredible parts but
because i mean there is only actually
the second order derivative v and
what you find is that this part of the
generator because it's the first starter
and it's actually cancelled out in this
integration of parts
and so after individual parts you only
get the gradient which is kind of you
like but that's only in the v direction
so there is no hope that this gradient
in the v direction can bound the l2 norm
because i mean the function for example
can depend only on x so that the
gradient vanishes by our dl2 normal plus
one dash
okay so this is the trouble that i mean
preventing us by using the simple
cohesivity estimate or the energy method
to
to prove the convergence
and to overcome that
the idea which dates back to uh
commander and also we were sort of
inspired by by by the work by um chris
and jean christopher
and so armstrong and the idea is to
actually we need to augment its state
space by also considering what's
happening uh not at instant time but
also within time duration from zero to t
okay
and so we consider the uh the augmented
state space so now it's not only x and v
but also we put in time t
and in that augmented time space
it's possible to establish a pancreatic
inequality of this kind
so this is a pancreatic inequality that
in augmented time space so that lambda
here is the back measure and from the
interval from 0 to t and mu is the
measure on the extended state space
and on the right hand side
we have the gradient
of v which is what you expected from the
generator but if you only use that term
there is no hope to control the
left-hand side and in order to control
the left-hand side we also need the
other part of the equation to help
okay so that this is the
this is a non-reversal part not a
reversible part of the dynamics in our
equation
and using together these two that you
are able to bound l2
okay
and now
if one are able to prove this inequality
and the rest of the analysis actually
just follows from a slightly modified
the energy estimate argument
so it's just because that if you write
down how the l2 norm changes remember
that i mean our all our analysis is chi
square or l2 so
this was actually the idea was borrowed
from the paper by armstrong
and you can rewrite that difference as a
time integral of the gradient of f so
that this is just followed from the
equation
okay
now using the equation we know that this
thing can be rewritten i mean as part of
that
as the as the other part of the equation
okay so because we know that the
equation is given by the time derivative
times the hamiltonian part is equal to
the fluctuation distribution part
so that this i mean we can rewrite this
thing
okay boundary from below by the other
parts of the equation
in l2 norm
so now you just split this term into two
parts one is this uh keeping some part
of the original and i mean and also
using the help from this term and now
using the concurrent quality that we can
use the sum of these two terms to
control the l2 norm so that putting them
together you can i mean so this is split
into two terms and putting them together
you can lower bound the
l2 norm or because we have an active
sign that here that we upper bounded
from the negative of the l to node
okay
so you get the expansion decay
and the rate i mean so for to get rates
you need to do some calculations to to
figure out what the exact rate is and
then uh by the way for those of uh the
people who are familiar with hmc so the
t
so the time duration that we need to
take here is actually proportional to
one over uh to get optimal rate this is
actually proportional to one over root
of m
so which means that uh for running the
hmc algorithm if you want to getting a
corresponding convergence rate the
dismissed hamiltonian flow needs to be
as long as that
uh but then the problem the problem is
that as far as i know if you run the
hvmc or the hemington dynamics for that
time duration it's very hard to
establish a good coupling
contraction argument so to get the
corresponding rate so as
so so far i mean even though that this
is suggesting this kind of time duration
but on the level of coupling we were not
able to get the convergence rate that is
uh that is matching i'm using the
coupling method
can i ask a quick question about the
center coil i'm a bit confused so if i
look at the
the right hand side of your fir so i'm
in the big display if i look at the
right hand side of the first uh row
and the left-hand side of the last row
it seems that you've proved again what
you said you could not prove that the
squared norm of f is upper bounded by uh
it's it's it's gradient which again you
know if f depends only on x this will be
zero and so yeah this is i mean so there
are two difference here so first of all
this is actually over a time interval
so this is integrated over time from
zero to t
and also i mean this is not for a
general f this is f being a solution of
our pde because i mean we use in this
inequality we use the fact that f solves
the uh backward chromograph equation
okay all right thank you
and there is no hope if you want to
prove this thing without the time
augmented so that that would be simply
false
term
yeah exactly so what i mean if i hear
lehan correctly is i mean what he was
saying that if you send this t to zero
then i mean these constants blows up so
that the uh the inequality is not valid
all right thank you
okay
so uh i
i mean to proof of the bunker inequality
i mean i don't think i have time to go
over these things but i mean if you are
interested uh you can talk to me
afterwards or maybe talk to lehigh but
the idea is actually not that difficult
in the sense that i mean we just tried
to do some individual parts but the most
technical step is to find the best right
test function to do the integration by
parts and for that one is a technical
lemma and so i'm going to skip that
proof i think
so to leave some uh so this is the
technical uh
uh construction of test function that we
need to make
and then after you construct it has the
function that things just follows from
like usual pd arguments
okay
so uh with that i think uh i think it's
a good time to stop and maybe leave some
time for questions so uh i've discussed
some of the quantitative analysis but
mostly on the continuous level
for these sampling dynamics that is
lounge event and i think
it's kind of interesting to think more
about these uh pdmp sampling dynamics
those exact quantity particle samplers
and so on so forth
and
the uh i think there are many many open
questions for example i mean what's the
optimal rate for the bouncy particle
sampler does that actually depend on the
dimension or not i mean remember that
our rate has a root d but it's not so
clear to us whether that's sharp or not
and also
try to i mean so i will show the
analysis of the uh
of uh of under some warm start
assumptions of the uh zigzag sampler
complexity uh but i mean to some extent
i mean the uh the assumption of the
warmness is not as great so whether it's
possible to remove that and in terms of
rate i mean there is a copper square
dependence there and which
i don't think is optimal and i mean so
for example how to improve that
these i think would be very interesting
directions if people want to work on
these
okay with that i want to conclude and if
you want to read more these papers are
listed here thank you for attention
i thank you for this great talk uh
jennifer do we have any questions let's
start with us and hope i'll get to you
hi um could you comment on what are the
difficulties of trying to do this like a
time augmented version of like a log
solve eleven equality for this setting
uh yeah so that's a very good question
and uh i think many asked
us this question and we also talked with
a couple of
uh many people on this so uh one
difficulty i guess is even to formulate
what should be the inequality and i mean
so that's uh already a bit unclear i
mean because i mean here you need the
terms like this to help and then of
course i mean if you think about logs of
life then the most straightforward
conjecture would be that to replace this
f by root sorry replace this f here by
root root f and replace these f's by
root f
that doesn't seem to work as far as we
can try to make it work um but
maybe that's um i mean maybe there are
some better ways to come up with uh the
right form of inequality and try to
prove it but i mean yeah so we are not
we do not really have much ideas how to
do that
just a naive question like what if what
if i keep the f's the way they are and
on the left-hand side i replace it with
like the entropy of of f squared
uh yeah i think that's equivalent way of
writing uh things
i say okay thank you
yeah one is the modified levels of
different ones lost obvious
i mean of course here the left-hand side
needs to be changed i'm not meaning to
control the l2 norm i'm controlling f
log f
um hi jim from the sitchin
um so
can i hear me i can hear you
oh right so so so your analysis very
much reminds me of this hyper core 70
analysis for um
velocil focal plank equation
so but
they they do require the support of
the support of x is basically the entire
domain used to encounter the same
difficulty
uh yeah i mean so here in our case
actually we need uh some
kind of gross assumptions of the i mean
so if i go back to
the main theorem
so i think you are kind of religious for
you have one slice that talks so that
you need actually youtube rose and then
the hashing of you is not too crazy so
that i mean so in particular i don't
think it would work if it's a compact
support uh right
yeah it's a similar issue yeah so i mean
by the way this uh this assumption
actually also appears in vlan's work of
hypocrisy
yeah the the second question i have is
um the the pi minus identity that
operator
looks very much like the bgk operator
yeah that's why it's called kinetic long
divine equation okay so
so uh there there are other collision
operators that drives the velocity
domain back to gaussian have you thought
about those
um i mean we haven't tried but i think i
mean to some extent i mean from our
analysis point of view
uh the
uh let me go back to here so from our
national point of view
if you use this or if you use if i mean
if you replace this by the uh what's
happening in the front
equation the fluctuate dissipation
operator actually they don't really
affect the rate
so i think as long as the collision
operator has a uniform spell uh gap and
then the gamma is is i mean you multiply
it in front with a gamma parameter i
think the behavior would be
all the same except with some like
absolute constant difference
oh i mean because we are doing two i
mean in language of kinetic equation we
are already i mean actually showing
determination rate for two kind of
collision operator one is uh the focal
plane collision and another is the bgk
collision
have you thought about boltzmann
uh well that makes things non-linear
right so that uh but it's a it's a
particle system so you have the
interaction between particles
yeah we haven't thought about it i mean
so for linearized boltzmann i believe
one can do something but you know i
don't know
okay
okay
okay
thank you
all right so we had a question over
there
hi gentle uh this is a very nice talk
and work as always uh quick question so
um you had both um
very nice results at the continuous
level and at the discrete level and you
talked about the proof um for the
continuous processes and uh can you say
a few words about how do you bridge um
to the to the discrete results
uh yeah that's a very good question so i
mean the difficulty is that we're
working chi-square right so there are
recent results that can uh analyze the
chi-square convergence for uh long-term
overtime long-term discretized
um and i mean so far we are not able to
i mean so just the difficulties to
control the chi-square uh
error
after do the discrimination and i mean
uh so far we are not able to get very
nice rates for these
okay thank you
all right so uh i'm going to uh stop
here and thank jeff frank for a great
talk to generate a lot of questions
thank you